a mini budget but this a generational
crisis inflation at a level not seen for
three decades and it's going to get
worse is there more pain to come
chancellor
rishi sunuk under pressure to meet the
scale of this moment
armed with a statement that for so many
will decide if they can heat their homes
and feed their families
from covered cost of living the
emergency chancellor promising to step
in again people should know
that we will stand by them as we have
throughout the last two years
today
i can announce
for only the second time in 20 years
fuel duty will be cut
[Music]
not by one not even by two but by five
pence per liter
[Music]
the biggest cut to all fuel duty rates
ever
a year long cut on fuel duty labour
bench is unimpressed
but the big reveal is still to come
easing the pain on the april national
insurance hike our current plan
is to increase the next threshold this
year by 300 pounds
but i'm not going to do that mr speaker
i'm going to increase it by the full 3
000 pounds
from this july people will be able to
earn twelve thousand five hundred and
seventy pounds a year without paying a
single penny of income or national
insurance
and a tax promise from a chancellor
already eyeing the next election
i can confirm
before the end of this parliament in
2024 for the first time in 16 years
the basic rate of income tax will be cut
from 20 to 19 pence in the pound
a tax cut for workers for pensioners for
savers a 5 billion pound tax cut for 30
million people
the opposition clear this simply not
enough inflation is at its highest level
for 30 years
and rising
energy prices at record highs
people are worried sick
for all his words it is clear that the
chancellor does not understand the scale
of the challenge
tax cuts always put a spring in the step
of conservative mps but the outlook far
from sunny official figures forecast the
biggest fall in living standards this
year since the 1950s
and minimal help today for the worst off
what the chancellor did today was to
help a little bit for people on
low to moderate earnings but he did
nothing at all actually for people who
are out of work and dependent on
benefits and they're really perhaps
going to find it the biggest struggle
over the next several months when that
next rise in energy prices comes next
one in april another one
around october i think there will be
more pressure on the chancellor because
there are going to be more
households particularly again the very
poorest who are really going to be
struggling at that point the chancellor
on a pr visit to a four court petrol
price is a big part of the problem
he surely knows the answer to that
for all the rhetoric around tax cuts
this mini budget really lived up to name
today this a package of measures that
barely even scratches the surface when
it comes to dealing with the biggest
fall in living standards in over 60
years the chancellor for now is biden
his time in the face of huge economic
uncertainty but one ally did concede to
me tonight that mr sunak is likely to
have to do more in the autumn if not
before
a chancellor who promised to stand
behind people in the pandemic now with
plenty to live up to and voters may
punish him and his party if they feel
abandoned bethrigby sky news